ALSO TONIGHT WE WILL TALK WITH
KELLY LESTER, HERE EXCLUSIVELY
AND WE BEGIN TONIGHT WITH PETER
NAVARRO.
THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH US.
GOOD TO HAVE YOU, SIR.
I WANT TO START WITH ASKING
ABOUT THE W.H.O.
SHOULD THE UNITED STATES NOT BE
PART OF THIS ORGANIZATION?
SHOULD WE CUT OFF FUNDING?
THE PRESIDENT OUTLINED THE HUGE
DISPARITY BETWEEN THE MONEY WE
PUT INTO IT AND THE MONEY CHINA
PUTS INTO IT.
>> MARTHA, LET ME GIVE YOU A
BIGGER LOOK AT THE CHESSBOARD.
THE U.N. ITSELF HAS 15
SPECIALIZED AGENCIES INCLUDING
THE W.H.O., THE WORLD
INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY
ORGANIZATION, THINGS LIKE THAT.
WHAT CHINA HAS BEEN DOING VERY
AGGRESSIVELY OVER THE LAST
DECADE IS TO TRY TO GAIN CONTROL
OF THOSE BY ELECTING PEOPLE TO
THE TOP.
IT’S ALREADY CONTROLLING FIVE OF
THE 15.
ALSO BY USING PROXIES LIKE
TEDROS AT THE W.H.O.
IN THIS CRISIS, THE DAMAGE THAT
KIND OF CONTROL BY CHINA, THE
KEY HEALTH ORGANIZATION HAS BEEN
ABSOLUTELY ENORMOUS.
THEY SUPPRESS THE HUMAN TO HUMAN
TRANSMISSION.
THEY REFUSED TO CALL IT A
PANDEMIC.
THEY BASICALLY DISCOURAGE TRAVEL
BAN’S.
THIS IS ONE OF THE MOST SERIOUS
THINGS WE’VE EVER SEEN AND IT
ALL TRACKS TO CHINA’S VIEW OF
THE WORLD AND HOW THEY WANT TO
CONTROL DIFFERENT TYPES OF
INTERNATIONAL ORGANIZATIONS,
EVEN AS THEY DON’T PLAY BY THE
INTERNATIONAL RULES.
SO IT’S GOING TO BE UP TO THE
PRESIDENT TO LOOK AT THIS BUT
MARTHA, THIS IS A REALLY SERIOUS
ISSUE.
THE PRESIDENT IS ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT ABOUT THIS.
>> Martha: LET ME ASK YOU IN
THE PAST, WE’VE SEEN THREE MAJOR
VIRUSES COME OUT OF CHINA, AND
SO IF WE CAN’T RELY ON THE WORLD
HEALTH ORGANIZATION, WE NEED TO
PERHAPS HAVE OUR OWN MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS OR ASSESSMENTS
SIMILAR TO THE IAEA OR SOMETHING
ALONG THOSE LINES WE HAVE IN THE
BED OF PEOPLE WHO CAN TAKE A
LOOK AT WHAT’S GOING ON IN
VARIOUS COUNTRIES AROUND THE
WORLD TO GIVE A HEADS UP IN
TERMS OF THE ACTUAL VIRUS OR THE
ACTUAL FUTURE PANDEMIC THAT’S
HAPPENING.
THERE HAS BEEN SOME CRITICISM
THAT MAY BE SOME OF THOSE
OUTREACH GROUPS DON’T EXIST
ANYMORE UNDER THE CURRENT
FRAMEWORK OF THE WHITE HOUSE
ORGANIZATION.
IS THAT SOMETHING THAT SHOULD BE
PUT BACK IN PLACE WOULD YOU SAY?
>> I THINK THE PROBLEM HERE, I
THINK ANY OTHER COUNTRY IN THE
WORLD WOULD’VE BEEN TRANSPARENT
ABOUT THE PROBLEM, WOULD HAVE
INVITED CDC PEOPLE IN.
WE LOST ABOUT FIVE WEEKS BECAUSE
OF CHINA’S NONTRANSPARENCY.
IF YOU’RE ASKING ME HOW ARE WE
GOING TO FIX IT?
IT’S KIND OF MORAVA CHINA
PROBLEM MORE THAN ANYTHING ELSE
AND I DON’T HAVE THE
ANSWER.
IT’S OUTSIDE OF MY LANE.
ALL I CAN KEEP TELLING YOU IS
THAT CHINA’S ATTEMPT TO CONTROL
BASICALLY EVERY ORGANIZATION
WITHIN THE UNITED NATIONS FOR
THEIR COLONIAL POWERS, THROUGH
BRIBERY AND OTHER THINGS,
TREMENDOUS DAMAGE TO THIS
COUNTRY INTO THE WORLD.
>> Martha: OKAY.
THERE’S BEEN A LOT OF DISCUSSION
ABOUT THE MEMOS THAT YOU SENT
OUT AT THE END OF JANUARY AND
TOWARDS THE END OF FEBRUARY.
TO THE NATIONAL SECURITY
COUNCIL.
HERE IS WHAT STEVE BANNON SAID
ABOUT THAT.
HE SAID, LET’S PUT THAT UP
THERE.
HE SAID THE PRINCIPAL REASON
PETER WROTE THIS MEMO IS TO MAKE
SURE REAL INFORMATION GOT TO THE
PRESIDENT, BECAUSE THE REAL
INFORMATION WAS BEING SUPPRESSED
BY THE CHIEF OF STAFF AT THE
TIME, MICK MULVANEY.
IS THAT TRUE?
>> LET ME MAKE SOMETHING CRYSTAL
CLEAR ABOUT THIS MEMO.
I HEARD A LOT OF CHATTER THIS
MORNING ON SOME OF THE LEFT-WING
CABLE NEWS CHANNELS.
THAT MEMO WENT NOT TO THE
PRESIDENT BUT TO A SMALL
DISTRIBUTION LIST TO THE
TASK FORCE.
PEOPLE THIS MORNING WHO WERE
CRITICIZING THE PRESIDENT FOR
NOT BOTHERING TO READ THE MEMO
OR WHATEVER, HE NEVER GOT THE
MEMO.
IT WAS NOT SENT TO HIM.
WHAT’S INTERESTING TO ME,
MARTHA, EVEN AS I WAS TRYING TO
PRESENT SIGNIFICANT ISSUES TO
THE TASK FORCE ITSELF, THE
PRESIDENT WAS ONE STEP AHEAD OF
ME.
BECAUSE AS I WAS ADVOCATING THE
TRAVEL BAN IN THAT MEMO TO THE
TASK FORCE, THE PRESIDENT WAS
ALREADY MOVING TO DO THAT.
HE DID THAT ON JANUARY 31ST.
I THINK THAT’S WHAT’S IMPORTANT
TO UNDERSTAND.
>> Martha: WE ARE AWARE OF
THAT.
>> WHAT I CAN TELL YOU ABOUT THE
TASK FORCE ITSELF AND WHY THAT
MEMO WENT FAIR IS THAT THERE WAS
DISAGREEMENT.
THAT’S NOT A BAD THING.
GO AHEAD.
>> Martha: I WANT TO ASK, IT
WAS ADDRESSED I BELIEVE TO TO TH
NATIONAL SECURITY COUNCIL.
IS THAT CORRECT?
THERE WAS NO TASK FORCE ON
CORONAVIRUS AT THAT POINT.
>> THAT’S NOT EXACTLY RIGHT.
THE TASK FORCE BEGAN
UNOFFICIALLY THAT MONDAY.
I APPEARED TUESDAY AT THE
TASK FORCE TO PRESENT THE CASE
VERBALLY AND BASED ON THE
DISCUSSION THERE, I FELT THE
NEED TO WRITE THAT MEMO.
THE CHIEF OF STAFF, THE MEMO
WENT --
>> Martha: THAT’S WHAT I WANT
TO ASK ABOUT.
YOU SAY THAT BASED ON THE
SITUATION THERE, DID
MICK MULVANEY, DID STEVE -- DID
MICK MULVANEY PUSH BACK AT YOU
AND DID YOU FEEL THE NEED TO
PUSH HARDER AND THAT’S WHY YOU
PUT THE MEMO OUT.
IS THAT TRUE OR NOT TRUE?
>> WHAT HAPPENS IN THE SITUATION
ROOM BY DEFINITION NEEDS TO STAY
THERE.
I CAN TELL YOU THAT THERE WAS
DISAGREEMENT AMONG THE
TASK FORCE ABOUT IT.
I TRIED TO PROVIDE SOME CLARITY
WITH A FAIRLY STRAIGHTFORWARD
ANALYSIS OF THE COSTS OF THE
TRAVEL BAN WHICH WOULD ENTAIL
DISRUPTIONS TO BUSINESS AND
TRAVEL VERSUS THE BIGGER COST.
WE DIDN’T KNOW THIS AT THE TIME
BUT IN CASE THE SERIOUSNESS OF
THE PANDEMIC EMERGED.
WHAT’S IMPORTANT IS THE
PRESIDENT INDEPENDENTLY OF THAT
MEMO MADE WHAT I THINK IN THE
HISTORY BOOKS WILL BE JUDGED AS
A PIVOTAL DECISION IN THE
CRISIS, AND IT STARTED IN MOTION
A SET OF EVENTS THAT HAVE LED TO
THE LARGEST INDUSTRIAL
MOBILIZATION SINCE WORLD WAR II.
IT HAS LED TO THE USE OF THE
DEFENSE PRODUCTION ACT FOR THE
FIRST TIME SINCE THE KOREAN WAR
TO GREAT EFFECT.
IT’S LED TO A QUARANTINE WHICH
WE HAD NEVER DONE BEFORE.
ALL OF THESE THINGS, THE
PRESIDENT GOT TREMENDOUS
RESISTANCE BUT AS EVERY DAY GOES
BY, WE SEE THAT HE WAS EXACTLY
RIGHT IN DOING WHAT HE DID.
HE HAS A GREATER SENSE OF THE
CHESSBOARD I THINK THAN ANYONE.
I HAVE SAID AND I’VE SAID THIS
REPEATEDLY PRIOR TO THE CRISIS,
I THINK HE WILL GO DOWN AS THE
GREATEST PRESIDENT IN MODERN
HISTORY FOR HIS POSITIONS ON
TRADE AND IMMIGRATION.
BUT I THINK IN THIS PARTICULAR
CASE, WHAT WE ARE SEEING IS
SOMEBODY PLAYING THE CHESS GAME
BETTER THAN ANYONE.
MY THOUGHT, WE HAVE JUST GOT TO
BEAT THIS VIRUS.
WE ARE AT WAR.
HE HAS A WARTIME PRESIDENT.
ALL OF THE STUFF ABOUT MEMOS AND
THINGS LIKE THAT, WE NEED TO
FOCUS ON GETTING MEDICINES TO
PEOPLE.
>> Martha: THAT’S BEEN OUR
FOCUS IN TERMS OF WATCHING THIS
VIRUS AND LOOKING AT IT.
IT’S INSTRUMENTAL AT SOME POINT
TO FIGURE OUT HOW IT ALL WENT
DOWN IN TERMS OF THE RESPONSE
WHICH HAS BEEN, YOU KNOW, I
THINK VERY STRONG IN MANY WAYS
WITH THE POSSIBLE EXCEPTION OF
THE TESTING THAT WAS A LITTLE
BIT BOTCHED AT THE BEGINNING.
REAL QUICK, THANK YOU GO AHEAD.
>> YESTERDAY WE GOT 9 MILLION
DOSES OF HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE TO
CHICAGO, DETROIT, NEW ORLEANS
AND NEW YORK.
TODAY AS WE SPEAK ARRIVING.
THERE WILL BE ANOTHER 8 MILLION
DOSES GOING TO TEN DIFFERENT
CITIES.
THIS IS MOVING IN TRUMP TIME.
THE KINDS OF THINGS I DO EVERY
DAY.
WE ARE GOING TO BEAT THIS VIRUS.
>> Martha: WE ARE GOING TO
TALK ABOUT THAT DRUG IS